>> Laura: BREAKING NEWS SAID,
FOX NEWS HAS LEARNED THAT
RECOMMENDED BRINGING CRIMINAL
CHARGES AGAINST DISGRACED FORMER
FBI DIRECTOR ANDREW McCABE.
WELL, THAT WAS FOR LYING ABOUT
LEAKING TO THE MEDIA.
MCCABE'S TEAM APPEALED THE
DECISION TO THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL MR. ROSEN WHO REJECTED
IT.
THAT DIDN'T STOP NBC FROM
DEFENDING McKAY.
>> EVEN IF THEY TRY TO MAKE THE
POINT IT WILL BE VERY HARD FOR
PEOPLE TO BELIEVE WHEN THEY SEE
ALL THE EVIDENCE LIKE THAT OF
THE COMMANDER IN CHIEF WANTING
TO BRING HIM DOWN.
SPEAK OUT NOW IT APPEARS THE
DEPARTMENT GOING TO PROSECUTE
HIM IN AN EXTREMELY WEAK CASE, A
CASE THAT LOOKS POLITICAL.
THE ONLY DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
ANTI-McCABE
AND OTHER DEPARTMENT EMPLOYEES
OVER THE YEAR IS THAT THEY
CALLED FOR HIM TO BE FIRED AND
CALL THEM TO BE PROSECUTED.
>> Laura: THEY DON'T EVEN HAVE
TO WORK AT THEIR NETWORK.
HERE IS RUDY GIULIANI JOINING ME
NOW.
RUDY, WHICH MSNBC CONTRIBUTOR DO
YOU PREDICT THE CABLE WILL HIRE
AS HIS NEXT COUNSEL?
>> I WOULD NOT HIRE ANY OF THEM.
BUT THE FACT THAT McCABE
DISGRACED AT THE FBI, FIRST OF
ALL BY LEAKING FBI AGENTS, BY
THE WAY, YOU'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO
LEAK.
IT'S THE MSNBC REPORTER, I LIKE
TO KNOW WHO THEY ARE.
BUT BEYOND THAT, HE COMPOUNDED
IT BY LEAKING TO CALL ME
UNLESS HE'S LYING AND UNLESS
CALL
HE'S TELLING THE TRUTH, YOU
DON'T KNOW.
McCABE IS THE ONE IN THE
MIDDLE RIGHT NOW.
THE NEXT IF YOU'RE GOING TO SEE
AND IT'S GOING TO TURN OUT TO
HAVE BEEN EVEN WORSE.
BECAUSE HE DIDN'T JUST MAKE AN
FALL STATEMENT COMEY LIED UNDER
OATH.
WITHOUT ANY DOUBTS, WHEN HE MADE
AN APPEARANCE STEALING THE
DOSSIER THAT WAS VINDICATED AND
VERIFIED WHICH IT WAS.
SO, I THINK THIS IS THE
BEGINNING OF INVESTIGATING AND
BRINGING OUT THE REAL CRIMES
THAT TOOK PLACE HERE.
WHICH IS HONESTLY, WHICH APPEARS
TO BE, AND EMERGING CONSPIRACY
TO FRAME DONALD TRUMP.
IN WHICH, IT CAN'T GET MUCH
BROADER HOW MUCH IS GOING TO
EVOLVE INTELLIGENCE SERVICES
ALSO WELL.
>> Laura: TO VINDICATE
HILLARY CLINTON.
KEEP THE INVESTIGATION GOING AND
ALSO TO VINDICATE HER RIGHT
BEFORE THE ELECTION.
OF >> THE HEADING AT THE BEGINNI
OF >> THE HEADING AT THE BEGINNG
OF A BOOK WOULD BE A STATEMENT,
HE LAID THE WHOLE THING OUT.
I HAVE A PLAN TO PREVENT IT FROM
BEING PRESIDENT AND HAVE AN
INSURANCE POLICY TO    TO TAKE H
INSURANCE POLICY TO    TO TAKE M
INSURANCE POLICY TO    TO TAKE O
INSURANCE POLICY TO    TO TAKE T
IF HE DOES BECOME PRESIDENT.
THAT'S WHAT THEY TRY TO DO.
>> Laura: WELL, CNN -- I THINK
HE MADE A BIG ERROR IN HIS
DEFENSE OF McCABE.
WATCH.
>> THIS IS AN EXTREMELY UNUSUAL
PROSECUTION.
ANTI-McCABE HAD THE RIGHT TO
SPEAK TO REPORTERS, THAT IS
BEYOND DISPUTED.
RECTOR OF THE FBI, HE OF THE
RIGHT TO SPEAK TO REPORTERS.
THERE IS EVERY BIT OF A TIME OF
VERY ADDICTIVE CRUSADE AGAINST
McCABE.
>> Laura: OF COURSE HE FILED A
LAWSUIT AGAINST THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT TO TRY TO REFER TO
ALL THIS.
APPEAL DEBTS.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT HE'S
TALKING ABOUT.
YOU HAVE AUTHORITY TO DISCLOSE
INFORMATION.
>> THAT'S A WHOLE NEW
PERSPECTIVE.
I DIDN'T HAVE AN IDEA I COULD
DISCLOSE INFORMATION TO THE
PRESS AND VIOLATES ABOUT TEN
DIFFERENT RULES OF JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
IT COULD EASILY AMOUNT TO A NOTE
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
HE LIED ABOUT IT, IS A FALSE
STATEMENT.
THEY ALSO PROSECUTED
MARTHA STEWART FOR A SINGLE FILE
STATEMENT TO THE FBI.
SHE WASN'T AN FBI AGENT.
IF PROSECUTING HIM FOR A SINGLE
FALSE STATEMENT WHEN THEY KNEW T
FALSE STATEMENT WHEN THEY KNEW E
ANSWER TO IT.
IF WE HAVE EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER
THE JET LAW, McCABE HAS TO BE
PROSECUTED AND SO
DOES STEVE       COMEY.
JUST BECAUSE THE DEMOCRATS OR
HILLARY DOESN'T GIVE THEM
IMMUNITY FROM THE LAW.
HILLARY GOT, WE GOT TO STOP
THIS.
IT'S BEYOND RUDY, THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S REPORT ALSO
CITED HE LIED FOR PERSONAL
GAIN WASN'T FOR THE PUBLIC
INTEREST.
THE -- IT WAS RIDICULOUS.
>> HIS WIFE WAS RUNNING FOR
OFFICE AND ARE TAKING MONEY FOR
CLINTON WHILE THEY'RE FIXING THE
CLINTON CASE.
NEVER MIND.
THESE PEOPLE -- THESE PEOPLE ARE
TRYING TO CREATE A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT SYSTEM OF JUSTICE.
SO THE CLINTONS AND THE
BIDENS -- THEY GET AWAY WITH
BRIBERY, PATENT ARE
, THEY ARE TAKING BILLIONS.
TAKING HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS FROM
RUSSIA.
OH, MY GOD, TIME IN
"THE WASHINGTON POST," YOU GET A
SINGLE FALSE STATEMENT AND A
TRAP BY GENERAL FLYNN.
YOU WANT TO CRUCIFY THE GUY.
THE CASE SHOULD BE DISMISSED.
>> Laura: IF THEY WANT TO
CRUCIFY THEM, BANKRUPT THEM.
>> IS A DISGRACE TO THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
>> Laura: I CAN'T GET OVER
THAT THEY PUT PAUL MANAFORT IN
SOLITARY CONFINEMENT.
>> THEY HAD THEM IN SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT FOR SEVEN MONTHS AND
THEY GAVE HIM A SCRIPT TO READ
FROM.
THEY TOLD HIM TO SAY WHAT WE
TOLD YOU TO SAY.
WE WILL LET YOU OUT OF SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT.
THEY SHOULD GO TO JAIL FOR DOING
THAT.
>> Laura: HEY, RUDY, CAN START
FORMER INDEPENDENT COUNSEL, HE
SPOKE OUT ON WHAT THE PENALTY
FOR McCABE COULD BE HERE.
WATCH.
>> THE CHURCH IS APPARENTLY
GOING TO
BE MISLEADING THE FBI.
FOR LYING.
THEY TALK ABOUT MISLEADING BUT
WE WILL SEE EXACTLY WHAT THE
INDICTMENT SAYS.
WE CAN BE LOOKING AT PRESENT
TIME HERE.
DON'T DESPAIR AND I CAN TELL YOU
HOW MANY
PEOPLE COME UP TO ME WHEN I
TRAVEL AROUND THE COUNTRY IS
ANYONE GOING TO GO TO JAIL HERE
WHY IS THERE NO ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR THESE LEAKS, VINDICTIVE
PROSECUTION, SORTED UP,
SURVEILLANCE, LYING TO THE
REPORT.
IF PEOPLE GET SO DEMORALIZED.
I'M TELLING YOU, MILITARY PEOPLE
DON'T GET AWAY WITH THE STUFF,
THEY GET THROWN AWAY FOR 20
YEARS.
>> THERE'S A LOT OF AMERICAN
PEOPLE WHO BELIEVE THAT JUSTICE
IS BLIND.
IT DOESN'T MATTER IF YOU'RE A
CROOK AND YOUR DEMOCRATS, OR IF
YOU'RE A CROOK AND A REPUBLICAN,
YOU GO TO JAIL.
RIGHT NOW, WE HAVE A SYSTEM OF
JUSTICE THAT I BELIEVE OBAMA
ORIGINALLY ORGANIZED IN WHICH
DEMOCRATS GET AWAY WITH
EGREGIOUS PERSONAL CONDUCT.
EGREGIOUS.
MULTIMILLIONS AND BRIBES.
REPUBLICANS GET PROSECUTED FOR
PROCESS CRIMES THAT HE WOULDN'T
PROSECUTE ANYONE FOR.
WE HAVE TO CHANGE THAT.
WE HAVE CROOKED REPUBLICANS, PUT
THEM IN JAIL.
I DIDN'T.
IF CRICKET, PUT THEM IN JAIL
"THE WASHINGTON POST" ENABLED
THIS WITH ALL THEIR RIDICULOUS
COVERAGE.
>> Laura: MOVING FORWARD WITH
THE PROCESS WITH THE PROCESS
BEING PUT IN PLACE FOR
IMPEACHMENT, ALEXANDRA GARCIA
CORTEZ, SHE DECIDED TO CHIME IN
TODAY ON THE VOTE THAT SHE WANTS
TO SEE COMING OUT OF THIS.
SPEAK UP THAT'S GENIUS.
SPEAK UP WE HAVE TO DO OUR JOB,O
SPEAK UP WE HAVE TO DO OUR JOB,C
SPEAK UP WE HAVE TO DO OUR JOB,E
THE HOUSE AND PEACHES, AND HOUSE
WILL
AND TEACH THE PRESIDENTS
I WANT TO SEE EVERY REPUBLICAN
GO OFF THE RECORD AND VOTE
AGAINST IMPEACHMENT OF THIS
PRESIDENT KNOWING HIS CORRUPTION
AND HAVING IT ON THE RECORD THAT
THEY CAN HAVE THAT FOR THE REST
OF THEIR LIVES.
>> Laura: RUDY, TAKE A SWING
AT THAT ONE.
>> I THINK AS A LAWYER AND A
PERSON WHO VALUES JUSTICE, MY
POLITICAL HEAD SAYS OKAY,
CORTEZ, DO IT.
YOU'RE GOING TO LOSE THE HOUSE.
YOU THINK THOSE 40 DEMOCRATS
THAT WERE ELECTED AND SWING
DISTRICTS VOTED FOR TRUMP.
IF YOU THINK THEY'RE GOING TO
GET REELECTED IF YOU DO
SOMETHING SO STUPID AS YOU
TEACH?
THE WHOLE CASE IS FALLING APART.
IT'S NOT ONLY NOW PROVEN THAT
TRUMP DIDN'T DO ANYTHING WRONG
IT'S BEGINNING TO EMERGE THAT
THE DEMOCRATS SET HIM UP.
COMEY McCABE, PEOPLE ON THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY.
>> Laura: 60% OF THE AMERICANS
AMERICANS.
THEY ARE AGAINST IMPEACHMENT.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT THEY CALL IN
NEW YORK?
IT WAS A FRAME UP.
DESIGNED IN THE OBAMA
WHITE HOUSE.
TO GET DIRTY INFORMATION FROM UR
TO GET DIRTY INFORMATION FROM UI
TO GET DIRTY INFORMATION FROM UE
TO GET DIRTY INFORMATION FROM U,
ENGLAND, ITALY, ANY PLACE THEY
GET IT.
SOMETHING THAT THEY COULD
CLEARLY FALSIFIED.
THEY SHOULD BOTH DETAIL FOR THAT
THEY SHOULD GO TO JAIL FOR THAT.